- I'm just excited for a new outfit.
I really, really enjoy
people reinterpreting
who I am, if that makes sense.
(sign creaks)
(upbeat music)
- Fashion, for me, is something
I take a lot of pride in.
- I dress more sharply,
and so I would like to break out of that.
- I roll out of bed like 30
minutes before I start work.
- I can picture Nick in my mind,
and I can picture clothes he's worn,
but I don't know if I ever had an opinion
about stuff he's wearing.
- [Nick] I, you know,
I put myself together,
and it looks halfway decent.
- I want to find a fun, patterned,
collared shirt, more like '80s and '90s.
- I think her wardrobe
is just a little bit
more daring and abrasive than mine is,
and I really like that, though.
- I mean, I have no idea what
that girl is gonna put me in.
- This is how much I know about fashion.
I'm like, I'll put Nick
in a shirt and pants.
Oh, it's gonna be great.
I straight up have never shopped
for a guy in my life, ever.
So we'll see.
I didn't know where to start,
there's so many options here
that when you first are sent
out, it's very very scary.
I had a couple of mini panic attacks.
These are pretty cute.
- Even though I don't dress the same way
as, say, Jazzmyne does, I can tell
that she has an eye for color and style.
- I was going for a street
vibe meets a Zack Morris vibe.
I really want squooshy pants.
Or should I have him
looking like Missy Elliott?
- I feel like I only notice clothes
if they are super flashy or are
obviously meant to be silly or bad.
Tiger's our intern.
Tiger, do you think this looks cool?
Would you wear it? Be honest.
- I'm not asking you any
more questions, Tiger.
You're clearly out to sabotage me.
- In order to be street-styled correctly,
you need a dope jacket.
Wow!
- I think if I went with
this jacket and this blue,
I think this actually looks really nice.
- [Voiceover] Don't fuck it up.
- I will, probably.
- I just hope it looks halfway decent.
- This is the thing, I don't
know how to shop for myself,
I certainly don't know
how to shop for a man.
- I'm excited I get to do this.
I used to walk around stores
and put outfits together,
and hope someone would pick them up.
I kind of don't mind shirts like these,
'cause they're so wrong.
- I guess what makes me
feel insecure about it
is that I feel like if I do a bad job,
everyone will make fun of me.
I just need to do something big.
- [Jazzmyne] 'Cause this
kind of matches with these.
- I think this is a perfect
shoe to go with this outfit
because the outfit in itself
is a little bit darker colored,
not super flashy.
I think this adds just
the right amount of glam.
And I think Nick is ready to
go out and solve a mystery,
a murder mystery, in the outfit I got him.
- I'm excited for it, I'd wear it.
- We're gonna go back to the office
and try all our stuff on.
(electric guitar)
(Nick and Jen laugh)
- [Jen] You can't pose like that.
- What the (bleep) is this?
It's some damn clown shoes.
(Jazzmyne laughs)
- Is this what you wanted?
- Not completely.
Tie this around your waist.
- Oh, now I get it.
- Oh my gosh, look at him!
- If I was a straight woman or a gay man,
I'd be like, wassup?
Look at all those patterns!
- I'm like a fashionable background extra
for Saved by the Bell.
- There we go.
- I never thought that I would be able
to pull off thrift-store chic.
- I'm really, really
happy with what I got.
And I also feel like he's
always very put together,
and I think this will help
him step out of his style,
into a style that's a
little bit more carefree
and just like, whatever.
- I'm just hoping that the great outfit
that she picked for me will inspire me
to continue dressing like that
and going off of that more.
- That (bleep) was a damn mess.
I mean, a trench coat, really?
Who wears trench coats?
Who wears polka dots with
other sorts of patterns?
I just, I can't.
- I guess it wasn't up to his style,
and I wouldn't wanna force somebody
to wear something they don't like.
So I will be okay if Nick
doesn't wear the outfit again.
(rock music)
(sign creaks)